[Music]
this week we've got
middle finger ghost divorce and silly
seals
silly sally seals i haven't thrown the
middle finger up in a while
me neither try it give it to me oh you
do an elegant one
yours is like the fingers all curl i do
like a [ __ ] like
this is the [ __ ] you make this the
longest yeah i feel like this is like
the little kid's
[ __ ] no because your yours is looking
like yeah you have to go like this mine
is like i'm gonna [ __ ]
here i feel like this is a nonchalant
[ __ ] no you you don't even you
you do this only i do both of these you
see oh this
one oh some people go like this one huh
oh i do this
i can't do that how do you do that
extend their middle finger like that
ever
let me pull these back so that's all so
this is so intentional this [ __ ] i do
a fist dude i make a [ __ ]
fist like you got a thumb over all your
lines
you don't realize how long this finger
is until you do this
[Laughter]
[ __ ] back can everyone screenshot these
right now and go
looks like a dick oh i don't do that
[ __ ] lazy [ __ ] we're happy
you're like fully fully bent right here
still too you gotta like stretch
i can't it's just really tight pow
[ __ ] is she really trying to get
in there aren't you just like like
yeah i got like a lazy middle finger i'm
like i like throw it away like you guys
see that [ __ ] twitter video where
those two guys were flipping each other
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you looks like they were
throwing hands you guys know the reason
why that cracked me up if you guys ever
watched [ __ ] that was like one of the
first scenes
yeah yeah it's like justin did his dad
going yeah yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you it immediately
reminded me of steve and nicki because
they have their middle finger fights
like
playing around i was like damn this is
so you guys
anyway for our first story this guy
spent four thousand dollars
to create a giant statue of the middle
finger
to uh flip off his neighbor the town
well not the whole town it's just like
these particular
town members so he wanted to build just
a certain size it's a dedicated two and
then their name
no it says uh so ten years ago ted
wanted to build an
8 000. 8 000 square foot garage so he
could move his
truck repair and recycling businesses
to his own property rather than to work
in the nearby town
but unfortunately the the review board
blocked him from getting a permit
over and over and over again so he just
got
sick and tired of it he's like he told
his wife one day after drinking two long
islands he's like you know what i'm
gonna build a
[ __ ] middle finger that kind of makes
sense though yeah i wouldn't want a
junkyard business next to my
house well it's not a junkyard business
um it's a
monofilament recycling business this one
is also an alcoholic
you know how many [ __ ] different
different two long islands two is
no no but you know how much [ __ ] you
have to have to make a long island it's
a cocktail
of like eight different things i heard
it's really like there's a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ] in there it's a really strong dream
yes there's like southern comfort
there's like you need to you need to
have
one of those bar things with like 20
different bottles
dude tim's wedding yeah they had that
their specialty drink at the bar was a
long island
yeah i hadn't had in long island is so
long i forgot how much alcohol was in
that [ __ ]
so in the beginning before the wedding
even started i had two of those
uh-oh two is the wrong number that's the
wrong number and then you built a giant
middle finger
and then out of the ice sculpture that
was a swan i made it to a middle finger
i started chipping away at it
david yeah so this you became an ice
sculptor
that's [ __ ] wild what was in that
long island 700 pound
block of pine that sits on top of a 16.
i pictured marvel but pine all right
so he commissioned it oh [ __ ] it is your
middle finger
yeah the fist one i like the
there you go like that look how extended
that [ __ ] is now
you i feel like a little kid yeah i feel
like that's how little kids do it
[ __ ] you oh it's good but it's funny
because on all the media sites they have
to blur out the finger and i saw this
one
what really yeah the cnn one it was like
it panned so it was like it panned like
this
and then it panned like this uh anybody
who's lived i was like separated
anybody who's lived in asia is that
is that also offensive in asia because
my dad points at everything like
too much my grandpa i learned from her
he changes the
channel and stuff and he like points
with the longest finger yeah it just
makes sense though
if you weren't about being like this
means [ __ ] off
like it's just so much more work though
to like put it down hold on
because we're just used to this yeah
cause they're used to this you're used
to this it's probably easy because my
dad
he used to when he would like point at
stuff he would do this and i would
giggle and then he would beat me up
after
my grandma would do that too she'll be
pointing at the like
i think kids point at things too because
i had maybe that's natural
and isaac too he naturally just pointed
at things with his middle finger with
this
with a singer huh i don't know that's
maybe that is natural but we have to
learn
if i'm like on the couch and i'm
reaching for something that's just too
far away from my index
then my middle finger for sure is next
that makes sense because if you look
down the line of your
your your arm the middle finger should
be the aligning thing that you
yeah if i look down my arm and i use my
index i'm like a
button off this looks off this looks
good
if your arm was a rifle you want to look
down the barrel
of the middle finger this is a random
thought though yesterday
um because i've been so congested and
[ __ ] i decided to like i was sick i
decided to take a bath
i realized how [ __ ] dumb this was
because i was trying to reach the
uh the the face soap that's on the top
of this rack thing
and i spent about five minutes doing
this like stretching my [ __ ] out
tiring as [ __ ] five minutes and i could
have just got stood up and just grabbed
it
but it's cold it's cold
it was so smooth you know what i do in
that situation
i go papa because after i go
he comes in with the camera i'm at the
office i have to drive all the way home
and you know what the dumping is
twice after i grabbed it it flipped and
it hit me in the [ __ ] head
and i just sat there i just went you
[ __ ] idiot
i've done stuff like that i've probably
done stuff where the bottle
is like over here i can't reach it i'll
probably grab
a handful of water and throw it at it
like it falls down
that's what i'm saying and then you just
think about it it's like i could have
just got up and grab it
and i wasted five i give he has long
hair he starts pulling on hair
trying to make it her broken i'm not i'm
not moving it's how either
lazy or dumb guys are dude it's like we
our laziness is the fact that we don't
want to get up and do it ourselves
but we're so [ __ ] stupid we're
actually doing more work it's because
there's moments though when it does work
and it falls down you're like that's
[ __ ] genius
that's true though because there's
moments where something's out and you
you try to throw something at it so
it'll fall forward yeah yeah and then
it'll be good enough to reach
yeah but then you realize you also have
to go for the thing you through now
so so you [ __ ] yourself over sometimes
it's perfect though like bounces back at
you
falls forward you're like we live for
those moments and nobody was there to
see it but you're like [ __ ]
yep by the way uh in that photo that
thing looks like a giant back scratcher
oh oh it does yeah yeah
so this takes place in vermont in this
city they banned
billboards but they technically can't do
anything about this because he's not
advertising
any businesses
okay legally it is so he's like man when
i heard that it was legal it was like
the most beautiful thing
who is it pointing at the whole town all
the towns the side of the town
he was like i just wanted to make sure
that the town knows it's not for them
it's for
the board the review board that kept
screwing me over
yeah all the neighbors like oh yeah
that's not for us that's for them
yeah it's okay you gotta dodge it when
you walk by well
that guy well if the review board lives
nowhere near that
you gotta do it in front of their homes
no because that's on his property
oh yeah well like the whole town's like
at that review board just like hahaha
it's for you guys
i was like it's in this direction but
it's for you
but it's in front of your house i like
how you did this snap like i'll snap
i don't think i've ever done that like
the whole sad part about this
what is the review board is probably
like oh okay
so on section 32 you want to no cause
they care about their town
do you think they really care though
dude they go outside and there's a
[ __ ] lit
back scratcher that's a middle finger in
my direction there's no way
i think they care if they already don't
let him build the garage he wants to
build he still got his way
way crazier than that or imagine like
seven months from now when they can't do
anything about it and they're used to it
that's funny too i just feel like a
bunch of asian people were to walk by
them and be like what's he pointing to
they keep looking up asian people are
gonna walk by be like
i don't care take a picture they would
put it like with their mouth like
they're gonna hold the hand up
they're gonna do this
that's good that was good all right for
our next story
this jack sparrow impersonator named
amanda she's irish what she
married a 300 year old pirate
ghost named what jolly roger
named jack teague he says that this
uh pirate is a haitian pirate from the
17th haitian pirate
who lived executed for thieving
he's a pirate he stole her heart oh
that's a good one dude that this affair
began
affair in 2014.
well how many doubloons did he steal
though i don't know you just wanted to
save the blooms [ __ ] you
how how often do i ever get to use them
no go for it what are the balloons
what are the blooms he's the pirate oh
yeah oh what's it what's it the blue
i think it's money okay is it the blooms
the balloon i think i don't know the
blooms any pirate experts out there
since everybody's expert on youtube
let's wait for the comments listen for
the comments you [ __ ] experts i think
it's like saying
dollar it's right there it's all yeah so
she said that she first felt
this spirit's energy with her in bed
and oh my god i get that energy too when
i masturbate let's go
and then that she sat with that the
spirit sat with her while watching tv
and drove her car and that she started
drove her car
oh get the [ __ ] out of here this is
hilarious though i love her
i thought she just like she was about to
get in her car she goes well if you want
to drive
she's watching tv and driving no not at
the same time
what are you saying tim
you guys are not this dumb i know
because she's someone she
lets him drive and watch tv no when
she's watching tv
comma and driving yes oh well the comma
wasn't there i had to say it no no no
you didn't pop
you did it i did pause you said when
she's watching tv and driving
and drove her car the sequence of what
she was watching
her car the point is that she started
developing strong feelings for the
spirits
and so she ended up marrying this guy
but what if oh never mind she had like a
whole ceremony
how many people went i don't know is he
there right now she did it in
international waters
and she says that he describes himself
as
like similar to jack sparrow character
from pirates of the caribbean so he
watches the movie
that's what i'm saying no no she made
the comparison because she is a jack
sparrow impersonator
oh that's good she used this painting of
jack sparrow and she's like
i didn't want to use a photograph
because then that would be of johnny
depp being
jack sparrow i had to be a painting of
them because this is what but it's still
a painting of a photograph of johnny
depp
yeah she was like this is
she's just in love with johnny depp what
the [ __ ] yeah that's what the real thing
is why does she have to pick like such
an attractive guy
no and then not only that but you know
how she says that
this pirate ghost name is jack teague
so in pirates of the caribbean the
character of
edward teague is the father of the
character jack sparrow
whose full name would be jack t so this
lady is just
yeah cause i like she's just obsessed
with jack sparrow's character yeah cause
like he
the real black dick though the real
pirate that's mine she chose that one
yeah she told
haitian the blood the real pirate would
have [ __ ] up teeth he would not be as
groomed he would not have
he would stink he would not have [ __ ]
black eyeliner
we don't know that what if this wool was
straight hunkered
like hunky dunk she said she doesn't
know what he looks like
but oh my god he looks like a [ __ ]
painting of a photo of johnny jeff
this is this is how he described himself
to her
i look like johnny depp this is someone
who reads pirate like
romance novels and [ __ ] thinks that
that's what like the whole pirate world
was this is like if i watch
goonies and think like that's that's how
pirates were in chile yeah yeah yeah i
didn't even tell you the
best part then tell us the best part
hurry up you're the best part
all right so she wrote on social media
this week
quote so i feel it's time to let
everyone know that my marriage is over
i will explain all in due course but for
now all i want to say is be
very careful when dabbling in
spirituality it's not something
oh no she's been cheating on the pirate
with the ninja
ninja both of them are never there they
always disappear so it makes sense he's
never here for me
because it's funny because she's shed an
affair with a pirate with who her real
husband no the husband the pirate is her
husband
but before that she had an affair with
no they they just called it an
affair like you know like the
relationship oh i thought an affair was
really like cheating and stuff i didn't
know that it could also just be an event
an affair
yeah like an affair yeah okay are you
going to the affair yes i am so then
people are like oh she goes
but in reality i like how they're trying
to disturb oh
she got spooked see you did it because
you did it oh
what the [ __ ] yeah what do you mean
i missed it it felt weird too i was like
where did i put my head oh it's like a
microphone the pirate wants her
in her jack sparrow outfit and the
pirate's actually gay
oh she didn't want to explain all that
she's like a a female that identifies as
a male pirate that also loves male
pirates that look like her yeah
you know she actually got the tattoos
and everything like the real
tattoo oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding
me from jack sparrow's character and
like even a gold tooth and all that [ __ ]
that's a committed cosplayer right there
that's gangster
there's a place for everybody in this
world there is there is i will say this
though
i like her because she has a purpose in
life yes that's a lot more than i could
say for most people i do vibe with what
joe is saying though she like probably
watched like specific pirate romance
novels
and she didn't watch like jackie chan's
movie foreigner
where like pirates like [ __ ] like
took his like daughters and wives and
like oh i just want to watch that
dude foreigner is actually pretty dope
man jackie chan's acting
that's like a different kind of like
pirates though and that's like a pirates
that
probably a lot of our like parents maybe
are more familiar with
or captain phillips oh i am the captain
i'm listening i'm the captain now i'm
the captain
heard they were actually like haitian
yes somalia
people dude they weren't even actors it
was amazing it was good
for our last story listen
listen to me i am the host now i am the
host now
all right so i'm getting more and more i
am the older i
am the host now my team this photo of a
seal with the
eel with the eel i know this
were they wearing teal oh i wish how did
it feel though it's a seal with an eel
and a nose joe's right it's the seal
with the eel in his nose oh no
that looks very painful can i tell this
story yeah tell it all right
so this is a phenomenon that has been
happening in our beloved
hawaiian island oh those are endangered
there is an endangered seal i think it's
called a monk seal
because these [ __ ] are killing them
well they're already endangered
but there's this weird phenomenon that's
been happening and eels are getting
stuck in their nose
and and so like they would find these uh
seals
on shore with [ __ ] eels just in their
nose like this
but they're not even bothered either
they're just chilling they're just yeah
well they can't do anything anymore
but the but he also looks high as [ __ ]
maybe they are
using it to get high so there's all
these theories out there one of them is
that
seals don't have hands so when they're
trying to let's put that's a theory
i was like what the [ __ ] now because
when you said that i just pictured this
blonde white guy in hawaii
let me tell you something right i have
this theory he has to take a hit first
seals don't have hands so because they
don't have hands they have to use their
face to look for food she has to hit it
with his flippers
and so when they're looking with their
they're using their face to look
i was thinking that too that an eel gets
stuck but then
um this researcher he's like nah that's
not possible it sounds high too
he's making him sound high he's like no
it's not possible seals
don't have hands the nose the muscles in
the steel
nose is too strong so like an eel can't
push through even though like you know
he might want to escape and that only
way to escape is through the nose he's
like that's not possible that means he's
sniffing it like a freaking coke line
another one another one is a defense
mech
that they think that like it's just a
mechanism
they think that the eel is trying to
defend itself
by attacking the uh seal's nose and then
it's getting stuck
oh yeah that's the one i just yeah
that's the muscle one that's the one
that i just said
how come that floor don't care though
the other one is that
seals they tend to regurgitate their
food out a lot and so like an eel
like a spaghetti yeah like out through
your nose but why is that but
what number one the last one that he
thinks is
the most plausible theory is that monk
seal teenagers aren't all that different
from their human counterparts and so
that they
like one seal just thought it was funny
to stick a eel up their nose and it's
like tide pods
but they don't have they don't have
hands well how is it sticking
i don't know somehow so one seal just
did that and the other seal teen was
laughing his ass off
oh [ __ ] so then like now all these like
seals are getting eels stuck on their
noses and so now this researcher's like
you know what it's going viral with the
seals oh trend right now that's
something he was like
i plead the seals if they could somehow
understand us if they could
to just make better choices don't be
doing these things just surgeon general
warning stickers on on you guys get to
see those seals in hawaii laying on a
beach yeah i think i saw one egg
they're huge dude and then there was
there was always a random white person
around them saying don't touch him with
caution tape yeah i saw it oh yeah yeah
yeah
they just camp out and [ __ ] put
caution tape around endangered things
i mean thank goodness for them yeah
thank goodness cause they'll just sit
there and make sure like we don't go up
and start poking them and [ __ ]
pick up like like the baby dolphin that
they picked up and yeah
did anybody think that like when you saw
the seal with the eel there
did anybody think about the idea or the
sensation of like if you were to like
pull that out
how satisfying that could feel that's
something that someone else tweeted but
then the researchers said that when they
pulled out the eel because initially it
was only like about two inches
out yeah but then they were like yeah it
was like a magician's handkerchief trick
like
we just kept pulling it out and then
that the seal was just like
chilling look how chill this will look
that's what i'm saying like doesn't it
no he looks like he's holding it in a
weird in a weird way
it seems like it'll be super satisfying
getting a long ass booger out of your
nose
yeah i really want to pet him
i like those videos where the seal where
somebody's laying down on a beach and a
seal just comes up and cuddles the guy
what i've never seen there's a video
there's a couple videos where for some
reason i don't know if because they are
so used to be having humans around them
but the dude was laying on his back
trying to take a picture
of a seal and the seal just started
coming up to me it was freaking out but
the stair just went up and just laid on
slept
you know how uh seals scratch their back
they use the back of their head to
scratch their back
[ __ ] dope as [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ] funny i can't stop thinking
about it they just go like this
[Music]
you